we're in a todrick shirt I'm sitting on
a WrestleMania chair and I'm trying to
have a Pinterest looking shelf behind me
I don't know what my brand is anymore
either
also sorry this guy right there that's
doing this and so that might be
bothersome and I just I I don't have
time for the Sun to ship hi my name is
hear something no no you know if it's
different now welcome to another cue and
Wednesday I went on my Facebook page
facebook.com slash grace Helbig and
asked you guys for questions that you
wanted answered so let's do it opinion
on this photo how dare you break into my
house and take a photo of me getting
breakfast
I really do eat blue cake icing for
breakfast sometimes and there's nothing
wrong with that
the only thing wrong with it is that you
haven't thought to do it yet so you're
welcome I'll work on my defense of this
who are you your worst nightmare
slightly awkward and pathetic adult
females who's desperate for your
attention via any means of social media
possible okay a millennial what's for
breakfast sometimes cake icing but today
straight-up had cold spaghetti the only
thing wrong good is that you love
himself to do this all right
fastest way to fall asleep help reach do
you like bread uh is the Queen of
England being weekend at Bernie's riddle
me that how do you get over a creative
bride turn it into a creative smut watch
pornography that's not the right answer
but maybe why grace member because I
wasn't currently giving myself enough
work and anxiety as goostman okay
what are you doing whoa what's your
opinion on people people are like aliens
I don't see them frequently but I
believe that they're out there can I be
the first question well that one up
where do you see yourself in ten years
older not funnier what not to do on the
first date anywhere but in a toilet why
didn't I buy more beer because you hate
yourself
do you eat ass is the queen being
weekend of burning but should I paint
your feelings
no that's eat paint food where do babies
come from poor decision-making house do
and grace never been so far not the
worst solid medium what do you guys
think what's your favorite bottom line I
primarily like Tito's but if
feeling nasty I get some silly blueberry
goose or goose yes carriers aim be
careful oh what a pleasant threat guys
I'm a hairy girl and I also prefer mr.
style sorry and also come on how do you
get comfortable in a long flight when
you have a middle seat you just fart it
out you're loud you've the middle seat
it's kind of a silent understanding that
the middle seat gets the fart all they
want to wear are some good self out
breeds or listens on audiobook right now
Grace's guide the order pretending to be
an adult it's the first one that comes
to mind grace what do you do if you want
to encourage your boyfriend to follow
his dreams but still pay half the rent
slash bills I always go for a passive
aggressive encouragement that builds a
strong resentment over time for him that
leads to a complicated and messy breakup
you could say one thing the goose that
she would understand what would you say
to her
face not other humans Pat you and not
feel constantly threatened unless I say
otherwise thank you what was the
weirdest thing you thought about when
you were a kid I really thought that
there was a transformer spikes outside
my window one night after seeing
Jurassic Park for the first time and it
wasn't doing anything I was just looking
but it was horrifying and I slept on the
floor of my parents bedroom if you could
trade places with any youtuber for a
week who would it be and why probably
Lilly Singh she's doing life right she
just she made choices and it's working
out and I wanted to see that firsthand
apart from being an amazing comedian
what do you hope to be doing get done in
2018 I hope to get some shows going
either scripted series's or live
performances that would be nice how do
you end up being a socially awkward
person and make guy friends find
socially awkward guys to be friends with
like aliens they're out there I am NOT
I'm your subscriber but can you mention
me anyway in next vid you got a shakti
how do you feel about being near the
full release of the killer slips out of
a hole unclench
you ever just stay in bed all day
because you just can't face
pulled out there oh yeah it's cute for
like a day and then it's Yetta you gotta
you gotta get out of this place is it
acceptable to nap at work if you work in
a sleep monitoring clinic I've asked
this lots of times
what's your myers-briggs personality I'm
an INFP on the myers-briggs personality
test scale sometimes called the mediator
for those of you that are familiar I'm
something Thanksgiving with my
boyfriend's family this year any advice
on topics for conversation religion
politics sexuality you'll either be
kicked out or will have left on your own
accord probably by the end of those
three topics covered when is your
membership to team 10 going to be
approved it's like one of my non
favorite party games forever in limbo if
you can redesign the shape of a hotdog
what shape would you mold it into for
everyone to enjoy she's perfect as it I
love your cooking videos is there going
to be a Thanksgiving food video if you
guys want it leave comments down below
if you want some sort of Thanksgiving
food cooking video thing of sorts and
stuff maybe okay there either meet me at
the live not you do podcast on Saturday
in New York City so excited for those of
you that don't know we're doing not too
deep live in New York City this Saturday
link for tickets is in the description
below please come buy your tickets iliza
shlesinger is our guest and the first
100 people that show up to the theater
are getting a free meet-and-greet with
jack and i after the show so please
please PLEASE buy your tickets there's
not many left so click and go ok that's
it for this Q&A I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did give this video a thumbs
up and click subscribe on this YouTube
channel because I'm making videos Monday
through Friday through the month of
grace member you don't want to miss it
it's not the worst I don't know how does
Chris feel about the current state of
the world this what you think about the
current state of the world same